I'm going to start with uh I've said
this uh uh to Christian already but um
this one of my favorite films of the
Year you guys are so good in this the
movie is so good I think I'm going to
start with the most important question
up front which is um Sandra what is the
proper viewing order of a double feature
between the zone of interest and anatomy
of a
fall I'm not going to answer
this I don't know you can't watch them
like because it's too long in a row go
on separate
days that's all I can say I'm
embarrassed I don't know I won't
pressure you guys I won't pressure um
but listen I am I am curious you never
know when you're making something what
the reaction is going to be from
audiences and from critics so for both
of you what actually has it been like
the reception to this film The Win
winning Awards and being the United
Kingdom's entry for the Academy
Awards I think um we are not doing or
making art for awards but the reception
is I'm I'm really lucky that Jonathan
Jonathan's Vision Works and this is
really great and if you Rec if you are
recognized for your work for all of our
work the whole team um working on this
move and so on and and this is makes me
really happy and and it's helpful hope
hopefully that many people watch this
movie and uh we said that it's a PO it's
it's a it's a movie for everyone U it's
it's an important for me it's an
sometimes it's hard to say that but it's
an important movie now on this difficult
political times and all these things are
happen now happening now um are very
helpful that people recognize this movie
exists and um yeah hopefully watching
this
movie not helpful there Bo I don't I
don't agree but um uh the the reception
so
far well it didn't start it didn't open
in Germany yet I think that's going to
be interesting what's going on there
because I think it's it the the
experience that you have as someone who
speaks actually speaks the language that
you hear in the film is different from
people who just hear it as a noise you
know who don't understand the language
even if they're subtitles so I think
yeah that's going to be interesting but
so far people are mostly very emotional
when they when they talk to us and um
I'm very grateful that we could like
connect with them and get yeah have an
impact on their way of thinking or even
on their lives one of the unique things
about this film is the way you actually
shot it and the way Jonathan allowed you
to do these long takes with hidden
cameras and it's not the norm on most
movies can you both talk about that
aspect of the film making uh for this
film I think I really like to
do this in this way observing thing it's
it was a luxury situation because when
we came to the set everything was
prepared there were no technical
interruptions and uh we had all the time
in the world and sometimes there was
some someone who's yelling cut someone
sometimes there were no one who yelling
cut and then we we're surprised okay
it's continuous sometimes we don't know
it's still rolling or recording or and
everything's is important now or what's
going on that
sometimes we were nervous or unsure what
we are doing here and but but it's it's
a great situation because we were more
searching than shooting sometimes I had
the feeling so because um for example we
had the dinner scene and one and a half
hour improvisations and the
improvisations are not in the movie
small parts of it but it's it was
helpful because
both of us said to Jonathan we are not
authors we we cannot play we cannot
improvise in a historical context but
sometimes the improvisation or the time
helps you to getting better into a
situation and I think that was really
helpful um to have no technical
interruptions all the time in the world
uh use your impuls sometimes you have
the impuls now I'm starting with with
the scene with the line or
surprising my colleague that I'm
starting now or sometimes not knowing
what's going on uh it's it's it's great
to start zero we all start from point
zero and then figuring out what's going
on and sometimes we failed sometimes it
was not good but it was
not yeah I think that was a great
experience um luxury experience for me
it's really unique this uh this uh this
technique and I hope more people are
going to use it depending on the story
they want to tell obviously but it makes
it so easy for actors to to be in that
place in in one way in the other way of
course the pressure is high because the
surveillance does something to you you
cannot hide anywhere you cannot there's
no place where you can put your actual
feelings or something you have to be in
this situation all the time at the same
time be with your partner all the time
which is a great thing so we would never
like lose the tension when the camera
would turn around like they normally do
um so everybody's in this together at
the same time and that is a great
experience in a way and also there's so
much space to I don't know to experience
the presence of even something else or
people who have lived there before or
whatever so there were there was a lot
of time and space to think about the
actual situation that you are in not
only filming wise but also in the place
as a person um and it requires obviously
a lot of trust towards the the filmmaker
the the director and everybody involved
because they see everything and they can
use everything you do you
can not hide your mistakes or when you
kind of drop out of something or you
have a like a laughing flesh in between
because the nerves or when you start
crying which the characters probably
wouldn't do you know he couldn't even go
to The Pantry like to the you know where
they store their food to hi you know
there was no place um and to be kind
of uh how do you say gang uh like yeah
imprisoned in a way like that to be
stuck in this situation has a an
enormous impact on the acting and the
The Experience yeah there I mean I can't
imagine as an actor not having
essentially downtime you can't shut it
off you're you're in character at all
times it's almost doing method you know
you're essentially
method yeah yeah I don't know anything
about that but maybe if you say so yeah
yeah yeah I'm just you know um I am
curious so you see the shooting schedule
and you know um I'm curious if you had a
what was a scene or sequence that you
had circled in the script or on the
shooting schedule either because you
were very nervous to film it or you were
very excited to film it that's a good
question for me I was the most I was
afraid of this last scene in the movie
uh when Rudolph is throwing up and uh um
because that that was a
personal fear uh because the last time I
throw up was 25 years ago and then you
said method acting we both H have an
theater background and of what we are
doing is is acting in a way so it's
sometimes technically or sometimes we we
connect ourselves with characters or
sometimes not but it's it's um method
acting means sometimes the dream to do a
documentary thing or the realness but I
think our work is to create a realness
you can believe um so and um and
sometimes here um
Jonathan was searching for that we not
act in a traditional way that we are
being in this situation and this scene I
was really afraid of this scene because
I know he wants that I'm
throwing real or but then we decided to
change this thing and it's more a battle
between body and soul and uh it was a
tough shoot
but uh yeah I was afraid of the shoot
and some of the scenes I was curious I
was thinking oh that could be fun in a
way or I was curious to do
this for example the scene horseback
riding or something uh to be in the
nature and to know that there will be
the same camera system 10 cameras in an
area of two kilometers hidden and you
are alone with your
film son alone horseback riding in
different uh tempies and that was really
wrong it's right but but it's um but
that was really it reminds me on my my
first movie there is a scene in the
white ribbon in in a in a carrier a
carrier scene and we were alone in the
nature only in the carriage alone with
my colleague and this is really that
that's it's really great to to to work
in this so but yeah the subject matter
sometimes I was yeah yeah what was
you now I didn't Circle a scene that I
found particularly hard or that I was
afraid
of no um make it quick talk so
long uh I'm basically out of time but I
just want to ask real fast is there as
an actor you're always looking for I
would you're always looking for your
next role and I am curious how much does
it play when you're being asked to play
a Nazi um does that factor into your
decision making as to whether or not you
want to take this role or is it sort of
like well this script is really good you
know what I mean like how much do you
think about that as an actor we both
think about it differently I think to me
it's an obstacle to go towards a project
it's something that I don't want to be
necessarily involved
with yes and I hope my next Nazi will be
in 10
years or very later or maybe I'm stucked
in this time because I had a lot of
projects uh but different characters in
and different subject matters um but but
for me the most important thing is the
vision of the director and it's
there is many things are important
um yes the script what he's or she's
thinking
about and and this is the most important
thing and then and if this is a new Nazi
role or
fascism I don't know but I had an offer
to doing another Nazi movie and and I
said immediately you even say it yeah
that that's so strange because sometimes
I don't I don't understand the
fantasy or because this project is I
want to give these yes it's it's a Nazi
but for me it's I want to give him a
human face for me all the characters at
play are human beings and and this is
the most and if I'm thinking okay this
vision is right or this is great or this
could be a great opportunity for me yeah
but but
yeah Nazis
it's I've done with
Nazis
yeah